use the commutative law of
multiplication the commutative law of
multiplication to write 2 times 34 in a
different way
simplify both expressions to show that
they have identical results so once
again this commutative law just means
that order doesn't matter it sounds very
fancy commutative law of multiplication
but all that says is it doesn't matter
whether we do 2 times 34 or whether we
do 34 times 2 the order does not matter
we can commute the two terms this shall
both of these are going to get you the
same exact answer so let's try it out
what is 2 times 34 and we could write it
like this literally you'll almost never
see it written like this but it is
literally 2 times 34 almost always
people write the larger digit on top or
the digit with more digits or the number
with more digits on top so let's do it
this way 4 times 2 is 8 and then we'll
put a 0 3 times 2 is 6 or you could view
it as 30 times 2 is 60 add them together
8 plus 0 is 8 6 bring it down it's not
being added to anything you get 68
so 2 times 34 is 68 now if you do 34
times 2 if we were to do 34 times 2 2
times 4 is 8 2 times 3 is 6 that's why
it's always nicer to write the number
with more digits on top it also is equal
to 68 so it doesn't matter whether you
have two groups of 34 or 34 groups of 2
in either case you're going to have 68